nicole kidman told us just a couple days
ago that you were the one that convinced
her to do bombshell what did you say to
her well I mean that's a no-brainer what
a great card what an important story to
tell more than half our nation gets its
news from this dubious source yes
bribery corruption money loss millions
and millions and millions of dollars
somebody has to sound the alarm there's
a lot of shady business in this film a
lot they're getting away with murder
which is bad when you see shadiness
going on I think I know the answer but
do you call it out or do you keep it
locked away I think when you're younger
and on your way up and more worried but
when you're old and mean and you don't
give up why fagioli
that's a bean that's an Italian bean
what do we do next it's easier to speak
up but it's hard for anybody to speak up
but we have to there's confusion over
who has to pay so they drown Joe and
plenty other innocent people and
somebody's making money from it so much
going on at tip running into co-stars
left and right I'm sure a little bit of
a big little lies link-up kosair
Shailene laura dern is here is here
whatever text you see I got a bandaid on
my thing so Zuckerberg can't see what
I'm doing or whatever meryl streep a new
cell phone please
he had a band-aid and so I thought I'm
getting a band-aid
this brand new TIF tribute award
congratulations what is it mean to you
to not just have a movie get an award
but it's just Meryl it's the Meryl award
now oh it's a it's a great honor and I'm
especially proud in this year that
Toronto is is
paying more attention to women than
maybe the other festivals it's out in
front of that issue its articulated it
as a matter of policy I appreciate that
and so do all my creative Court so yeah
that's great and it's great to be here
[Music]